l'heure de pointe d'un vendredi de la
fin ou dans la deuxième plus grande
ville de suède
ils sont près d'un million à vivre dans
la région de göteborg
c'est beaucoup moins de résidents qu'à
montréal mais la population ici et quand
même une habituée des bouchons sauf que
depuis deux ans ces bouchons sont 12%
moins important qu'à 20 depuis en fait
que la ville a instauré une taxe sur la
congestion routière à göteborg 37 postes
de contrôle entoure le centre ville les
plaques des voitures y sont prises en
photo et on envoie une facture mensuelle
à leurs propriétaires kaufman & broad
jonas marine travail pour transport ce
tir lcen l' agence suédoise des
transports qui administre ce péage et
celui de stockholm ceinture et le centre
ville dit il était la meilleure façon
d'avoir un péage avec de l'impact
c'est une taxe sur la congestion
si on veut vraiment la réduire au centre
ville alors on a besoin de ces postes de
contrôle il dresse un bilan plutôt
positif après deux ans même si leur
espérait encore moins de voitures sur
les routes